a Twitter question yes we had a question
come in on Twitter two days ago and will
will leave the person's name off just in
case they don't want it there but I'm
sure they're ok with it but they just
asked I'd like to know how one secures a
pitch meeting with executives or
production companies as they first-time
screenwriter and then they followed it
up with I mean does one just make a call
and set a date and time do you go in
with a treatment or dot dot dot and
there's more of it but so ok I I'm
thinking yeah yeah that's that that's
that's a that's quite a question how do
you secure a meeting you write a
screenplay and you write a really really
good screenplay and the metaphysics of
getting a meeting after that are so
elusive sorry I'm not a and it's a very
sincere question and I it gets asked to
me all the time and I'm going so I'm
gonna dance around it a little bit but
I'm gonna but again not seriously but
sincerely there was a time when I was
teaching and that here's something about
me me as a teacher I am AI I'm a
screenwriting teacher who's not a failed
screenwriter I'm actually a successful
screenwriter who teaches at the same
time oh god that was cheap I apologize
but I I stopped I stopped teaching at
one point because I really have an
ethical dilemma
because I thought the real reason people
were taking my classes is to say to me
how do you get a movie made
you've gotten movies made you've gotten
through the door how do I get through
the door and I could have been teaching
anything that could story analysis
screenplay structure dialogue anything
and I thought the real reason that
people were there was to ask me Larry
Wilson how do I get a pitch meaning how
do I get a movie mate
how do I get through the door and I
didn't know what to say I didn't know
what to say and I felt like I was like
part of this false hope machine and I
didn't like it and I didn't like the way
it made me feel and I stopped teaching
and the thing that brought me back to
teaching and where I could do it again
were a question like that which I wish I
had a great answer III look I've I've
been blessed by the fact that doors open
unexpected doors open for me my entire
life
after I moved to Hollywood I was working
in a department store stocking makeup
because I'd worked because I'd cleaned
my mother's beauty shop for years and I
knew how to stock makeup and the woman
who loved the way I stock your makeup
said oh it's a you want to be in like
the the entertainment business well you
should do cue cards and she introduced
me to a man named Barney McNulty and the
next thing I knew was I was doing cue
cards and all the biggest television
shows of the time a door open I can't
explain why that happened
why went in stocking makeup in that door
open luck and all of that it's too
complex of a question but and but I knew
it was what people were asking I hope
this is making sense I know so what
people were asking me really how do I
get through the door how do how do I get
my script read by someone that matters
well there's some easy Pat answers to
that they're not pat but you know
there's there's there's contest there's
pit for geezers all that you know these
millions of things out there that you
need to be careful about what you submit
to but there's all those ways but there
is no answer the question but the and
and I got very I I really started I had
a
think of dilemma about it I did not want
to be trafficking in false hope and then
I had some magical answer so the first
part of the answer was right a really
great scrub but the reason I was able to
come back to teaching was the digital
revolution and the fact that you could
make a movie holding up my cell phone
ladies and gentlemen you can make a
movie on your cell phone now you can
make a movie for a thousand bucks there
is no excuse for you not to make a movie
anymore and knowing that and knowing
that I could go in and help people write
a great screenplay and that they and if
no one would give them the time of day
they could figure out how to write a
great screenplay that they could shoot
for five hundred dollars on their iPhone
inspired me to come back to teaching and
the answer is there is no answer the
answer is you you put yourself in every
possible place conceivable place you can
think of without getting ripped off by
sham screenplay contest and all that you
put yourself in every conceivable place
you can think of you submit your script
anywhere you possibly can it can you
talk to anyone who you think might be
able to help you and maybe that door
will open for you but if none of that
works make your own movie sorry you know
I I and and and and I and and it's it's
it's it's a great place to be but it's a
scary place for people to be when I
started in in the business a billion
years ago making a movie was expense
just a film stock could stop you from
making a movie the cost of printing and
developing and dailies and all of that
could stop you from making a movie don't
wasn't that people didn't do it but it's
incredibly difficult but the digital
revolution if you can't get your stuff
seen if you can't get a pitch meeting
shoot a film shoot shoot a ten minute
short and post it on YouTube
take your career and your life into your
own hands and stop waiting for these
gatekeepers to give you permission to be
a filmmaker
and you can at the same time you're
trying to get through that door and
you're trying to get that pitch meeting
and you're trying to get that huge movie
off the ground
do all of that but be making your your
iPhone movie be and and and and and it's
an answer that people don't want to hear
why why do you think they don't want to
hear it because because it puts all the
responsibility on them it makes them it
makes them have to make a movie it makes
them have to do something in public and
perhaps fail
it makes them have to go to their mother
and say can I have a thousand bucks mom
why well I want to make a movie if you
think I'm going to spend a thousand
dollars I I mean you know it's it just
puts all the responsibility back on you
as a screenwriter and a filmmaker and
people hate that they want that ticket
that that is going to open that door and
I wish I had an answer I have struggled
with that question for decades of
teaching and I don't know why these
doors opened for me I don't know I know
I was persistent I was idiotically
persistent I literally was that that
doofus who went around to the guard
gates at studios and said I want to make
a movie how do I make a movie sir you
know to a to a gate guard I mean I
literally did that because I was so dumb
I didn't know any better but one of them
finally said to me well son what do you
what do you do well I read will then
become a script reader how do I do that
well you ask someone and I got a job $75
a week reading scripts and it was and
then I got it you know and then I was
like working you know and a cosmetic
counter and a may company and that and I
you know I mean it's just stupid stuff
that that's the way life works or
doesn't work for you but the whole the
whole landscape has changed where anyone
can make a movie now what that means is
there will be millions of bad movies but
make sure yours is a good one and you
know and and
God here built it and they will come or
whatever that is so that's the best
answer I can give and it's not
I wish question and ask her I could give
you a better answer but it's the only
answer I can honestly give you because I
don't know
you